chu de pointe-à-pitre jeudi une
impression d'heure de pointe
devant le centre hospitalier
l'attention se mêlent très vite à la
frustration
tu n'es ce pas c'est le patient qui va
venir à ma consultation
mais tu as compris
et même toi tu vois venir me voir
je trouve sympa bien sûr bon je sais pas
qu'est-ce qu'il n'est pas bon
l'accès au chu est en effet
partiellement bloqué depuis cinq jours
pour protester contre l'obligation
vaccinale se faire soigner ou encore à
exercer sa profession
ressemble à un parcours du combattant
j'ai à nouveau ce matin je n'ai pas eu
du mal à passer parce que j dans le taxi
puis j'ai décidé à marcher dans ce qui
fait que
on n'a pas eu de problème à passer cette
semaine il ya les barrages routiers qui
pénalise énormément le personnel qui
vient de tout horizon qu'est-ce qu'ils
soient médical ou paramédical
donc c'est vrai qu'on est obligé
d'attendre que tout le monde soit
présent pour démarrer
ces dernières heures les manifestants
ont durci leurs actions coup de poing
plusieurs barrages de pneus ont été
dressées parfois incendiés tout comme ce
véhicule calciné à proximité du siège du
service départemental d'incendié et de
secours
les forces de l'ordre sont sur le
qui-vive devant le chu mais également
mobilisés sur d'autres axes routiers et
dans la compagnie guadeloupéen
le préfet du département d'outre-mer a
dénoncé les derniers actes de violence
comme certains jets de projectiles
message reçu à paris par le ministère de
l'intérieur
face aux violences qui touchent
actuellement la guadeloupe nous avons
décidé avec sébastien lecornu ministre d
outre-mer de déployer 200 policiers et
gendarmes supplémentaires dans les
prochains jours afin de rétablir l'ordre
républicain soutien aux forces de
l'ordre et services de l'état mobilisé
le gouvernement est confronté à une
possibilité d'embrasement du département
la colère des guadeloupéens semble
perdurer après des rassemblements au
mois de septembre et en août dernier la
défiance face à la vaccination n'a
jamais été aussi fort sur l'île où 38%
de la population avait reçu au moins une
dose fin octobre
[Musique]
déboussolé face aux décisions venant de
la métropole de plus en plus de
manifestants sont déterminés à
revendiquer leur liberté donc on pense à
l'uqam et l'obligation vaccinale
l'obligation vaccinale est derrière ce
sport un personnel l'ensemble des
travailleurs dans tous les secteurs
d'activités qui sont mobilisés pour dire
non à l'obligation vaccinale non au pas
sa météo oui à la liberté
et avec l'instauration d'un couvre-feu
dès ce vendredi le préfet de guadeloupe
a également interdit la vente d'essence
en jerrycans jusqu'à nouvel ordre